>> So I'm Will Swope. I run sustainability
for Intel. And the question I want to address
is dealing with the economy verse dealing
with the environment. And my simple message
in return is, we should never let this crisis
go to waste. As in a personal level here are
things we can do. We can do two less, two
less degrees of heat, two less degrees of
cooling. Two less car trips a week. We can
do one less. One less meal of meat a week.
One more conservation effort a week. And there's
one more thing we can do more of. Which is
think through how we deal with recycling and
think through how we deal with an energy audit.
Now, at the big level, at the collective level.
There are issues that we have to go deal with.
We have to deal with the economics of the
two places in the world that can absorb carbon
dioxide. Which is the ocean and the rainforest.
We don't really have either of those worked
out today. And we need to change the language,
the way we describe energy sources. They're
not alternative energy sources, they're sustainable
energy sources. These may sound simplistic,
but the fact of the matter is that if each
individual can make the kind of changes we're
talking about and help the collective make
the macro arguments that we talked about,
the world will be a better place.